a family battle is unfolding in a New
Hampshire Court over a seven million
dollar inheritance and a pair of
suspicious deaths
Nathan Carmen appeared in court
yesterday representing himself after
firing his attorneys Carmen's aunts
believe he murdered his grandfather and
his mother to receive the inheritance
Don Dahler has been looking into the
case he's in Concord New Hampshire Don
good morning good morning
Nathan Carmen has not been charged in
either case and maintains his innocence
but his aunts are not convinced they
filed a lawsuit to try to keep his hands
off the inheritance but at a hearing at
this courthouse yesterday he tried to
turn the tables on them Nathan Carmen
told a civil court judge he had nothing
to do with his grandfather's death he
also denied abandoning his mother on a
sinking boat during their doomed fishing
trip instead carmen pointed the finger
at his aunts who are trying to stop him
from getting the 7 million dollars his
grandfather had left behind for his
mother carmen has been described as a
person of interest by police and the
unsolved murder of his grandfather John
chuckle os-- the wealthy real estate
developer was shot in his Connecticut
home in 2013 according to court
documents carmen was the last known
person to see ciccolo alive and
allegedly owned the same caliber rifle
as the murder weapon used Carmen's
mother Linda vanished at sea in 2016 and
is presumed dead Nathan who spent eight
days floating in a life raft before he
was rescued told the Coast Guard his
fishing boat experienced engine trouble
and sank in the Atlantic Ocean Nathan we
believe is a cold calculating killer
attorney Dan small represents Carmen's
aunts both of these crimes were done
carefully and we are very concerned that
if he gets away with it he will kill
again the arts the odds attorney says
that charges against his clients by
Carmen are
nonsense now Carmen's involved in
another lawsuit the insurance company
that covered the boat says he made
modifications to it that caused it to
sink john dunn tanks how much tricky
when you're your own lawyer
[Music]